اعلنا كل من مجلس السياده السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع موافقتهما المشروطه على
العوده الى مسار جده تفوضي الرامي لارساء
وقف مستدام لاطلاق النار وكان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الاعتبارات التي حكمت موقف الجيش والدعم
السريع في السودان من العوده الى مفاوضات
جده وكيف تبدو صله هذا المسار بغيره كذلك
الذي تقوده الايجاد وما الذي بوسع المجتمع
الدولي فعله في هذه المرحله من الازمه
لاحداث اختراق النوعي وملزم في جدارها
[موسيقى]
انا اعتقد انه موقف القوات المسلحه اصلا
لم يحدث فيه اي تغيير وهات المسلحه منذ
بدايه الحرب هي مع تحقيق السلام وايجاد حل
فيلمي لهذه الازمه من خلال التفاوض ولكن
يجب ان يبقى التفاوض اولا بتحسين الوضع
الانساني او الظروف التي جعلت الجميع
يذهبون الى التفاوض من جديد هي تعثر
العمليات العسكريه وفشل الجيش في العمليات
التي اعلن عنها وسمها بانها من اجل
التنهاء التمرد وكذلك من اجل فك الخناق
على القياده العامه وعلى القيادات
الكبرى التي تحاصرها يعني قوات الدعم
السريع في المدرعات وفي المهندسين وكذلك
في القياده العامه وكذلك الحديث الذي بدا
يتصاعد حول فراغ في القياده بان السودان
ليس لديه قياده
وتتحمل المسؤوليه وتتصدى لهذه المهمه
الكبيره وانها عاجزه عن التفاوض وعاجزه عن
الحرب وكذلك عجزه عن تمثيل المواظ في
الدفاع عنهم القوات المسلحه منذ البدايه
تقول ان الحل السياسي لن يكون الا بعد ان
تنتهي هذه الحرب اثناء الحرب لا مجالا لاي
حديث عن حد وهذا هو نفس الموقف الان الان
لا مجال للحديث عن عن اي شان سياسي الان
الحديث عن وصف الاطلاق النار
يحسن الوضع الانساني تخرج عناصر التمرد من
منازل المواطنين تخرج من المناطق الخدميه
تخرج من المستشفيات يعود المواطنين الى
منزله يكون هنالك وقفه لاطلاق النار ثم
بعد ذلك ندخل في مفاوضات لايجاد حل لهذه
الازمه
لا يزال طويلا قبل التوصل الى اتفاق بين
القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم الساريه
للاتفاق على وقف لاطلاق النار يكون دائما
مستمرا مستداما وتحترمه الاطراف جميعها
اعتقد ان هناك توقعات
متدنيه
في الاجتماعات المرتقبه في جده من المهم
ان تقام من المهم ان نحاول ولكن لا اعتقد
ان الكثير قد تغير حتى الان
[موسيقى]
مفاجات ايجاد كانت تاتي في اطار المؤامره
الاقليميه ضد السودان بالتنسيق الدعم
السريعه المتمرد هذه المؤامره التي كان
يقودها الرئيس الكيني وانا اقول ذلك
ومسؤول عن هذا الحديث هذه مؤامره كانت
تتحدث عن هنالك فراغ في القياده هنالك
كبير جدا بسياده في السودان تم في قمه
ايجاد ولذلك السودان رفضت هذه القمه جمله
ان تفصيلا لا يمكن لقوات شرق افريقيا
تتدخل في اي دوله وفقا لقانونها بدون
موافقه الدوله المعنيه وكل مخرجات ايجاد
تعتبر الان في ملقيه تماما كل مطالع ابد
الحرف هناك تعقيدات كثيره جدا الانسانيه
وكذلك تعقيدات يعني فيما يخص حقوق الانسان
هذا كله يحتاج الى تحقيق ويحتاج الى ضبط
يعني وبالتالي الطريقه الامثل والطريق
الاقصر لوقف هذه الانتهاكات هو وقف الحرب
والاتفاق على تركيبات سياسيه وامنيه يعني
لوقف الحرب وكذلك للمضي قدما في اصلاح
الاجهزه الامنيه الاجهزه التي فشلت في
حمايه المدنيين
انا لست متفائلا كثيرا بشان نتائج هذه
الجهود التي ستبذل من اجل التوصل الى هدنه
او وقفان طويل الامد لاطلاق النار وفتح
ممرات انسانيه وتعامل مع الازمه السودانيه
الانسانيه من المهم بذل جهود من اجل
التقدم في
مفاوضات السلام لعل وعسى هذه المفاوضات
تنجح انا لست متفائلا لان الجهود الكثيره
بدرت من قبل وفشلت بمجرد ان طرفين تعهد
باحترام وقف اطلاق النار وفعل ذلك لفتره
قصيره قبل انهيار وقفه اطلاق النار
والعوده الى الاقتتال الولايات المتحده قد
فرضت عددا من العقوبات وذلك على الطرفين
ولكن لم تحقق انجازات كبيره
بقيت عقوبات قليله يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان تفرضها
ما تبقى هو ان الدول التي تدعم او التي
دعمت في الماضي طرفا او اخر يجب ان تتوقف
عن هذا الدعم هذا من شانه ان يؤثر ربما